with the help of your elected leaders
here today we had an extraordinary two
years of progress we passed the American
Rescue plan
now
everybody knows it but we did so much no
one knows the effects of it yet we're
just just they're just coming into play
you have to live the bill in order to
appreciate it now expect to hear a lot
of that kind of useless inaccurate
problem over the next two years now
according to axios Biden's speech in
Michigan today is kind of a dry run for
what's to come at his potential 2024 run
now apparently White House advisors see
the midterms as the ultimate validation
that voters are concerned about
protecting democracy women's
Reproductive Rights and giving Biden
passing grades apparently on the economy
because isn't the economy great he also
they also point out that Biden's 2020
bunker strategy look at work like a
charm
relating to axios that Americans seem
unbothered by his constant weekends away
in Delaware or at Camp David in other
words we can expect Biden's basement
strategy 2.0 joining me now Molly
Hemingway editor-in-chief of the
Federalists Fox News contributor and
Monica Crowley a rare appearance in
Washington former Trump's treasury
assistant secretary hosted the Monica
Crowley podcast all right Molly just
days after his 80th the octogenarian um
does team Biden seem a bit overconfident
is this a is this kind of a little game
they're playing here they just want to
seem like they're not lame duck at this
point well to some extent they have
reason to be confident their strategy in
2020 did work out well you had the
corporate media running the campaign
Biden could stay in the pandemic um yeah
yeah and then in the 2022 you had
similar things with the with the media
helping the Biden Administration Biden
wasn't on the ballot in 2022 though and
so redoing this strategy I think is
unlikely to work well given that now
people have so much
awareness of what it's like to live
under the under the Biden Administration
and it only works well for him to run
the same type of campaign if you have
drastic improvements in the economy and
I don't think anybody's predicting that
now Monica earlier today Biden was asked
for asked everyone for a bit of patience
on the economy watch
we can increase production and lower
prices for American consumers and
businesses in the short term all
accelerating our investment and
transition to a clean energy future
and not we're going to do that we're
doing it it's going to take time to get
inflation back to normal levels as we
keep the job market resilient
Monica is this going to work no it's not
going to work I mean patience the man
has been in office now for two years and
look at what he's done the economy is in
historic catastrophe Remember When
Donald Trump handed off the economy to
Joe Biden in January of 2021 he handed
him the fastest economic recovery from
any crisis on record inflation was at
1.4 percent so all of this economic
catastrophe that we are living through
now with astronomical inflation high gas
prices supply chain crisis now maybe a
Railroad Strike all of this is a direct
result of the Biden Administration and
unified Democratic control over the last
uh two years in terms of pushing so much
money down into the system creating this
inflationary environment that every
American is suffering through right now
he cannot turn it around because as he
said right after the midterms Laura he's
not going to change course he's not
going to change course because he's
completely committed to what Obama once
called the fundamental transformation of
the nation so there will be no course
correction they can't they certainly
can't change their policies now Molly
today after that Oath Keepers verdict
that they were salivating over all
afternoon long and into the evening at
the other cables Democrat Congressman
Jamie Raskin leaned into another key
strategy for the Dems in 2024. the
election that we just came through was a
very positive thing in terms of the vast
majority of the American people trying
to stand up for democracy and freedom
and the Constitutional framework but we
have to remember that Donald Trump and
the forces of chaos and Vendetta and
authoritarianism are still very much out
there
Molly this is representing an
Administration that refuses to condemn
what's happening in China but apparently
I guess any crowd of Republicans is
going to be an Insurrection from now on
well it's interesting coming from Jamie
Raskin someone who didn't just reject
the results of the 2016 election but
also famously wrote about his belief
that George W bush and Dick Cheney had
stolen their election it's very common
to hear this type of rhetoric from
Democrats but I do think it speaks to
something that's important for
Republicans to recognize Democrats have
been able to make some of these messages
go unchecked and I think a lot of
Americans are wondering where is the
Republican party to stand up for the
fact that there are two standards of
Justice in this country and that a lot
of people who have been Republican that
you know there seems to be an attempt to
criminalize this thing and also Jamie
Raskin should remember that in his uh in
in this election people did choose to
give the House Representatives to
Republicans probably in part to stop
some of these uh things that were
happening with the j6 committee and
other things all right ladies thank you
great to see both of you tonight hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else